el comandante ucraniano de las fuerzas
terrestres en el este del país llegó a
Bad mood horas después de que el líder
del grupo de Mercenario rusos Wagner
dijera que la ciudad está casi
completamente rodeada y pidiera las
tropas ucranianas que abandonen la urbe
sumida en una de las batallas más largas
de la guerra
avanza la gira del presidente francés
por África Central Emanuel macron se
encuentra en el Congo para renovar Los
lazos económicos con bras hábil
previamente el mandatario francés visitó
Angola donde firmó un acuerdo
agroindustrial
en Panamá la conferencia Howard Ocean
reúne a gobiernos empresarios y sociedad
civil de todo el mundo para pactar
compromisos que ayuden a proteger los
océanos el evento se realiza por primera
vez en Centroamérica y france24 está
presente
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de France 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
Mateo y es para mí un gusto acompañarles
abrimos esta edición con noticias de la
guerra en Ucrania porque a esta hora
avanza la intensa batalla por el control
de bacmut en el don Bach una de las
batallas más largas de la guerra que
podría entrar ya en sus últimas horas
este viernes el comandante del ejército
de tierra ucraniano para el este del
país visitó a las tropas que defienden
la ciudad del asedio ruso la llegada del
comandante ucraniano tuvo lugar pocas
horas después de que el líder del grupo
Wagner pidiera las tropas de kiev que
abandonen badmud Dado que los rusos la
tienen prácticamente rodeada
el cerco se hiciera alrededor de bajutes
ese fue el mensaje transmitido por el
fundador del grupo paramilitar ruso
Wagner en un vídeo publicado el viernes
se dirigió directamente al presidente
ucraniano
las unidades del grupo Wagner han
rodeado efectivamente Bad mood Solo
queda un camino las pinzas se están
cerrando anteriormente luchábamos contra
el ejército profesional ucraniano pero
hoy nos enfrentamos cada vez más a los
ancianos y los niños están luchando
contra nosotros pero sus vidas en
backmud son cortas uno o dos días denles
la oportunidad de salir de la ciudad la
ciudad está realmente rodeada
el vídeo muestra a tres ucranianos
capturados pidiendo que les dejen volver
a casa si bahamut caes sería la primera
Gran Victoria de Moscú en medio año
durante meses Wagner ha encabezado el
asalto a la ciudad que una vez fue el
hogar de alrededor de 70.000 personas
ahora la mayoría de la población se ha
ido algunos han huido a un territorio
que ahora está bajo control ruso
este Refugio a unas dos horas al sur de
bahamutes el líder separatista de Doña
es Dennis
que habían abandonado recientemente su
ciudad esta familia dice que fueron
evacuados por combatientes de Wagner
estábamos esperando la evacuación porque
no queríamos ir a Ucrania queríamos ir a
Rusia
esperaron y ocurrió esperamos en los
sótanos
el control del ejército ucraniano sobre
la ciudad parece Ahora más tenue que
nunca el viernes temprano por la mañana
el comandante de una unidad ucraniana de
aviones no tripulados en bahmud dijo que
se le había ordenado retirarse de la
ciudad
y en Washington el presidente de Estados
Unidos Joe biden recibió al canciller
alemán olafones un encuentro con la
guerra en Ucrania en el centro de la
agenda en el despacho oval de la Casa
Blanca biden agradeció a shortles su
aumento en el gasto militar Para apoyar
a kiev frente a la invasión rusa para
ampliar conectamos ahora con nuestro
corresponsal en la capital
estadounidense Cristóbal Vázquez
Cristóbal buenas tardes qué detalles
concretamente se conocen a esta hora al
respecto de lo que ambos líderes
hablaron sobre Ucrania
la reunión duró aproximadamente una hora
y no ninguno de los dos líderes quiso
hablar con la prensa sin embargo antes
de esta reunión bilateral en el salón
oval de la Casa Blanca se refirieron al
tema de Ucrania el canciller Olaf dijo
que este era un año muy importante
teniendo en cuenta la nueva ofensiva
rusa para tratar de seguir ganando
terreno en Ucrania hay que recordar que
esta es la Segunda visita del canciller
alemán desde que llegó al poder hace 15
meses la primera visita fue precisamente
dos semanas antes de que empezara la
invasión rusa a Ucrania al respecto Joe
biden dijo que pues había que centrar el
interés todas las fuerzas en la unidad
transatlántica dijo que las relaciones
entre Alemania y Estados Unidos estaban
en su mejor momento y se comprometieron
los dos líderes a seguir trabajando para
ayudar a Ucrania en su defensa contra
Rusia el tiempo que sea necesario y con
los recursos que sea necesarios y
Cristóbal por otro lado dejando al lado
la guerra en Ucrania que otros temas son
prioridad en la agenda de ambos países
de hecho en llamadas previas a este
encuentro que oficiales de la Casa
Blanca Siguen con periodistas el tema de
China fue uno de los temas que más se le
preguntó a los oficiales de la Casa
Blanca sobre si iba a ser uno de los
temas que sí iban a tratar antes
precisamente de la reunión a Puerta
cerrada de los dos líderes los
periodistas gritaron varias preguntas
sobre chinas y China estaba sobre la
mesa y es que preocupa mucho el tema de
que china vaya a ayudar no solamente a
nivel militar sino a nivel logístico a
Rusia en su ataque a Ucrania y lo que se
está discutiendo es Cuáles van a ser los
próximos pasos en caso de una eventual
ayuda china a Rusia y también está sobre
la mesa obviamente lo que se ha venido
preguntando mucho
los medios acá en Estados Unidos es
cuando va a ser el anuncio si lo hace el
presidente estadounidense sobre la el
envío de los jets de los aviones f-16 a
Ucrania esto Obviamente con el apoyo de
Alemania que termina siendo con el Reino
Unido los tres países que más ayuda
militar y ayuda financiera han dado
Ucrania desde que empezó la guerra
además a este Resaltar que el fiscal
general de Estados Unidos Maryland
estuvo y en Ucrania hoy
Esto pues obviamente ha aprendido las
alarmas de porque el fiscal general de
Estados Unidos lleva a Ucrania y hay que
recordar que esta es su Segunda visita
desde que empezó la guerra también
Cristóbal Muchísimas gracias por su
reporte Seguiremos de cerca este debate
sobre los aviones de combate y también
sobre esta potencial ayuda china a Rusia
Que de momento las autoridades de
Beijing niegan y rechazan nosotros
cambiamos de información porque en el
marco de su gira centroafricana el
presidente francés Emmanuel macron se
encuentra ya en el Congo donde fue
recibido por el presidente Denis sashall
gueso en este viaje macron pretende
renovar las relaciones económicas con el
continente africano de hecho previamente
estuvo en Angola donde presenció la
firma de un acuerdo agroindustrial con
luanda recordemos que Angola no fue
Colonia francesa pero que París ha
desarrollado importantes lazos
comerciales con el país el mayor
productor de petróleo de África y donde
operan multinacionales francesas como
total energys
como decíamos el objetivo declarado del
mandatario francés en este viaje es
redibujar las relaciones entre Francia y
el continente africano en sus propias
palabras hacerlas Más igualitarias sin
embargo macron también dijo que quiere
favorecer la influencia de la Unión
Europea en el Continente una región
donde recordemos China y Rusia ganan
cada vez más terreno en República
democrática del Congo muchos ciudadanos
rechazan la visita de macron y la
influencia francesa
ahora quiere seducirnos quiere volver a
colonizar el Congo porque entiende que
gran parte de África occidental le está
dando la espalda a Francia
ahora quiere venir a África Central a
seducir y buscar una sociedad y seguir
colonizando
en África decimos que no
siento que si el enemigo invisible se
hace visible es una buena oportunidad
para hablar con el cara a cara sobre lo
que está pasando en el este del Congo
vamos con noticias de nuestra región
Porque la fiscal general de Ecuador
Diana Salazar solicitó este viernes el
arresto domiciliario para el
expresidente Lenin Moreno por un caso de
corrupción la decisión se da en el marco
del caso sino hidro que gira en torno a
presuntos sobornos recibidos por la
construcción de la central
hidroeléctrica coca codo Sinclair la
fiscal consideró necesaria la prisión
preventiva para los 37 imputados en el
caso pero la Constitución impide esa
medida para los mayores de 65 años como
es el caso de Moreno
seguimos en América Latina porque la
Corte Suprema de chile condenó a 59
miembros de la antigua Dina la dirección
de policía secreta de la dictadura de
Augusto pinochet por su implicación en
la tortura y el secuestro de 16
militantes de izquierda del total de 119
que fueron Víctimas de la llamada
operación Colombo en 1974 la sentencia
revoca así un fallo anterior del
tribunal de apelaciones y condena a
altas penas de prisión a antiguos
funcionarios de la dictadura el
periodista Leonardo honores del pino con
los detalles desde Santiago
la resolución de la Corte Suprema que es
conocimos durante esta jornada marca un
antes y un después en causas de Derechos
Humanos aquí en chile se condenó a 59
exagentes de La dictadura todos
integrantes de la dirección de
inteligencia nacional ladina una de las
organizaciones de represión de la
dictadura de Augusto pinochet son
condenados por la muerte de 16 personas
esto en el barco de la investigación de
la denominada operación Colombo que fue
un operativo un montaje que desarrolló
la dictadura para hacer pasar la muerte
de opositores a ella como Víctimas de
enfrentamientos y de operativos también
fuera de las fronteras chilenas sin
embargo todos estaban detenidos en
centros de reclusión clandestina en
nuestro país en donde estaban siendo
torturados años atrás en esta causa
todos los imputados habían sido
absueltos así que con esta resolución
judicial se ratifica su culpabilidad y
responsabilidad en estos hechos
revocándose esta decisión de años atrás
de la corte de apelaciones
específicamente los abogados de Derechos
Humanos han dicho que esta definición de
la corte de Suprema en Chile el máximo
tribunal del país marca un antes y un
después específicamente por su
relevancia entre otras cosas porque este
año el 2023 se cumplen 50 años del golpe
de estado en Chile
vamos ahora a Panamá allí los expertos
científicos y líderes en materia de
océanos están en la recta final de la
conferencia ower Ocean y antes de
terminar están planteando el tema del
turismo responsable en lugares como
México y es que tan solo en el estado de
Baja California Sur recibe 3,3 millones
de turistas cada año y cerca del 40% de
Los visitantes viajan Por las playas del
país nuestra enviada especial María
Clara calle nos cuenta más
economía azul y turismo sostenible han
sido dos de los temas centrales de este
segundo día de la conferencia award
Ocean Y es que el océano no solamente
nos provee vida sino también un recurso
económico para hablar de eso nos
acompaña Mario Gómez el fundador y
director de la organización mexicana
Beta diversidad Mario gracias por estar
con nosotros y bueno Qué significa
turismo sostenible sobre todo en una
región como donde usted las está
proponiendo Baja California Sur bien el
turismo como lo comentaba yo hace unos
minutos una conferencia es una
oportunidad o una amenaza Yo creo que el
turismo creciente que tenemos ahí es
básicamente el turismo que está
representado por la biodiversidad que
existe es un área muy rica es un
ecosistema Marino extraordinariamente
exquisito que está beneficiado por los
las la corriente que viene del Ártico
que es la corriente de California y la
corriente ecuatorial que cuando se
cruzan una una de ellas impulsa a la
otra corriente la parte interior del
Golfo de California que también
conocemos turísticamente Como mar de
Cortés y cómo es la situación de la
sobrepesca en esta confluencia de las
dos corrientes en esa región se pescan
el 70% de Las capturas que hace México
se Ejecutan en esa región sobre pesca es
básicamente la industria pesquera lo que
en una ciudad turística como los cabos
capturan una embarcación pesquera en una
noche es lo que capturan todas las
comunidades asentadas desde Los Cabos
hasta la paz a 400 kilómetros de
distancia pero en todo el año Entonces
eso te dice en automático las
diferencias entre saber pescar bien como
Los Pescadores ribereños que pescan de
uno por uno o una industria que con un
barco se puede llevar la pesca de todas
las comunidades en una noche lo que
pescan ellos en un año sobre pesca como
una de las grandes amenazas de los
océanos y turismo como también una
amenaza o también una solución
y finalizamos con el centenario de la
revista Time en medio de información más
leído en Estados Unidos cumple un siglo
con más de un millón de suscriptores y
más de 5.000 números a sus espaldas su
primera portada la protagonizó el
legislador republicano conocido como tío
show que entonces anunciaba su retiro
mientras servía como presidente de la
cámara de representantes y veamos ahora
5 ediciones icónicas en abril de 1966
una portada completamente negra con
letras rojas alzaba la
preguntad Dios está muerto en español en
mayo de 2012 un polémico titular eres lo
suficientemente mamá donde aparece un
niño de 3 años siendo amamantado por su
madre en 2001 la imagen es la del ataque
a las torres gemelas de Nueva York
mientras que en 2010 vemos El retrato de
asha una mujer afgana a quien los
talibanes le cortaron la nariz y las
orejas finalmente en 2019 la impactante
imagen del entonces presidente Donald
Trump Mirando a una niña migrante que
llora con el título Bienvenidos a
Estados Unidos
llegamos así al final de esta emisión
pero sigan con nosotros en France 24
punto com
[Música]